High tax rates damage Britain's
competitiveness
they reduced the incentive to work to
invest and to start a business and the
higher the tax the more ways people seek
to avoid them or work elsewhere or
simply work less rather than putting
their time and effort to more creative
and productive ends take the additional
rate of income tax at 45 percent it is
currently higher than the headline top
rate in G7 countries like the US and
Italy and it is even higher than social
democracies like Norway
but I'm not going to cut the additional
rate of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
from April the 23rd we will have the
high a single higher rate of income tax
of 40 this will simplify the tax system
and make Britain more competitive it'll
reward Enterprise and work it will
incentivize growth it'll benefit the
whole economy and the whole country and
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
after all after all this only returns us
this only returns us to the top rate we
had for 20 years including the entire
time the opposition was lost in power
about one month for one month and that's
not all I can announce today that we
will cut the basic rate of income tax to
19 pence in April 2023 one year early
that means a tax cut for over 31 million
people in just a few months time this
means that we will have one of the most
competitive and pro-growth income tax
systems in the world Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker for too long in this country
we've indulged in a fight over
redistribution yeah now we need to focus
on growth not just how we tax and spend
we won't apologize for managing the
economy in a way that increases
prosperity and living standards our
entire focus is on making Britain more
globally competitive not losing out to
our competitors abroad